hello John Perry here I am back for yet
another episode of science versus the
Ark Encounter
in this much-anticipated episode we will
take a look at ken ham's Mars exhibit
that's right as odd as it might sound an
entire section of the Ark Encounter is
dedicated to presenting evidence that
Mars once had flowing water on its
surface in it we read despite the fact
that there is no known liquid water on
the surface of Mars many scientists
believe that Mars once suffered a flood
of biblical proportions ironically many
of these same scientists deny that Earth
a planet 70% covered with water ever had
a global flood now it certainly is true
that Mars seems to have once had an
ocean on its surface but the scientists
really believe that Mars suffered quote
a flood of biblical proportions continue
watching to find out
[Music]
[Music]
hello good people of the Internet
it's good to be back here doing another
science versus the Ark Encounter video
I'm really excited about today's because
today we're going to talk about Mars and
the the really strange properties of
Mars and the really strange properties
of water that make it so that today
liquid water cannot exist on the surface
of Mars if you were to take a bottle of
water and open it up on the surface of
Mars it would not remain liquid in the
past however there is evidence that a
huge ocean once existed on Mars we're
going to talk about this today but first
I need to draw your attention to another
exhibit at the Ark Encounter and if I
recall correctly this exhibit is
actually right next to the Mars exhibit
it's an exhibit on the nature of the
flood according to Ken hams
interpretation of the Bible so a lot of
you probably know that Ken hams
interpretation of the Bible is not the
only interpretation of the Bible that's
out there there are lots of Christians
that believe that the flood happened but
it it was a local event it was not a
global event and there's a whole bunch
of different variations of this that you
can find in Christian literature Ken Ham
has an exhibit that makes fun of those
other ideas because there's a verse in
the Bible saying that the waters covered
the mountaintops and so he has this
image right here mocking people that
believe that there was a local flood and
saying that this is what it would look
like if there was a local flood that
covered the mountaintops and Ken Ham
goes on to say that his interpretation
of the Bible it and he thinks that his
interpretation is the only legitimate
interpretation of the Bible according to
his interpretation a flood of biblical
proportions as they flood where the
entire planet is completely covered in
water and all of the mountaintops are
completely covered in water this is what
a flood of biblical proportions is
according to Ken Ham now I want you to
remember that it might seem irrelevant
right now but remember that because
we're going to come back to that later
Ken Ham defines a flood of biblical
proportions as a global flood that
covers all of the mountains with water
so back to Mars a few years back there
was a paper published in the journal
Nature describing an overview of all
different lines of evidence that
scientists have discovered telling us
that Mars once had a giant ocean on its
surface and in this paper we learned
that the ocean covered about 1/3 of the
planet that's what we predict based on
the observations that we have of water
flow ancient water flow on the surface
of Mars now again there is no liquid
water on the surface of Mars today there
is ice on the polar caps of Mars and a
lot of that ice is co2 ice it's it's dry
ice and a lot of it is water ice
there's also liquid water under the
surface of Mars but on the surface of
Mars we have not found any significant
bodies of liquid water and we do not
expect to find any significant bodies of
liquid water and so when you learn this
you might be like well why on earth do
we believe that there was water in the
past when we believe that there is water
in the past because there's evidence of
it there's these valleys and different
waterways that could only have been
carved out so far as we know by large
amounts of liquid and by studying the
composition of Mars we think that that
liquid was water the reason that today
Mars can no longer have liquid water on
its surface is that Mars has lost its
atmosphere evidence suggests that in the
past Mars had a nice thick atmosphere
possibly as thick as the atmosphere here
on earth this nice thick atmosphere was
what allowed Mars to have liquid water
on its surface
Mars gradually lost its atmosphere for
several reasons one of which is that
Mars is much smaller than Earth and
because it's smaller and because gravity
is a property of mass Mars has less
gravity than Earth does and gravity is
what keeps the gases in our atmosphere
trapped close to the surface of Earth
and so on Mars because there's not just
less gravity a lot of those gases were
able to slowly just kind of bounce away
and escape into outer space furthermore
Mars does not have a magnetic shield
Earth's magnetic shield protects us from
solar winds and so Mars is actually
subject to all of the violence of solar
winds so solar winds are also knocking
off
gases and they're getting lost in space
and because of this and there's a couple
other reasons that have been proposed
Mars over time lost its atmosphere and
and without atmospheric pressure liquid
water cannot exist so you probably
learned in middle school this is this
here is a glass of water with some food
coloring in it you probably learned in
middle school that water is made of a
collection of molecules that those
molecules are constantly bouncing off of
each other so all these water molecules
are hitting each other bouncing around
and doing their thing when water freezes
those molecules they essentially stop
moving that's what solid ice is its
water molecules that are no longer
moving that's when they become ice and
then water vapor is when the water
molecules you know in liquid they're
bouncing off each other but they're kind
of staying together and water vapor in
its gas form the water molecules are
just bouncing all over the place
like just going crazy the reason water
is a liquid on earth at room temperature
there's there's three main reasons one
is that gravity is pulling them down so
it's the water molecules are pulled by
gravity and collecting in the bottom of
this cup but gravity actually doesn't
have very much of an influence on them
that's not the most important part
what's far more important is that water
molecules are slightly attracted to each
other a part of the water molecule is
positive and a part of the water
molecule is negative they have what you
could sort of think of as a magnetic
attraction to one another and that's
part of what keeps all of these water
molecules here and liquid form it stops
them from it stops the water from
evaporating and just turning into a gas
and then the most important thing is air
pressure there is on top of this water a
whole bunch of air molecules you know
the our our atmosphere the entire depth
of our atmosphere all that pressure all
that weight of those gas molecules in
our atmosphere is pressing down on the
top of this water and it's pressing down
on this and keeping the water altogether
in my cup if I were to remove all of the
gas
the water would start to expand and
eventually it would turn into water
vapor here on earth the atmospheric
pressure at sea level is about 14 pounds
per square inch
there's 14 pounds of pressure per square
inch pressing down on the top of this
water that's what's keeping it all
together
that's what's keeping it down here in
this Cup on Mars because the atmosphere
has dissipated the atmospheric pressure
is greatly reduced compared to the
atmospheric pressure on earth and today
the atmospheric pressure on Mars is
about point zero eight seven pounds per
square inch not even a single pound of
pressure on Mars because of that if I
were to take this glass of water onto
Mars it would start to evaporate most of
it would evaporate and some of it would
turn into ice and then that ice would
slowly go through a process called
sublimation
it would actually turn from ice into
water vapor when you melt ice on Mars
because that the atmospheric pressure is
so low instead of turning into a liquid
it just turns right into a gas and it
just starts bouncing around in the
atmosphere now we all learned about this
in middle school right but if you'd like
to really know the details of it because
we didn't you know when I was in school
I didn't learn much about the details of
why this happens if you really want to
understand in depth why this happens
there is a wonderful video by another
YouTube channel called Cody's lab and
there Cody actually takes a glass of
water and he puts it into a vacuum
chamber reduces the atmospheric pressure
in that vacuum chamber and you watch the
water boil at room temperature and you
watch a chunk of that water freeze at
room temperature and he explains all the
physics behind what's going on there
it's really fascinating so just to kind
of sum things up here scientists have
found massive amounts of evidence that
Mars used to have a thicker atmosphere
and an ocean on its surface according to
our best estimates the ocean looked
something like this and it covered about
1/3 of Mars surface so Ken Ham
summarizes some of this information in
his Mars exhibit and then from that
information
he explains despite the fact that there
is no known liquid on the surface of
Mars many scientists believe that Mars
once suffered a flood of biblical
proportions I
many of these same scientists deny that
Earth a planet 70% covered with water
ever had a global flood so here in Ken
hams Mars exhibit we find that according
to Ken Ham a flood that covers one-third
of a planet surface is a flood of
biblical proportions meanwhile right
down the hall there is another exhibit
where Ken Ham explains that a flood of
biblical proportions as a flood that
covers an entire planet surface anything
else would be just ridiculous according
to his interpretation of the Bible in
our last few videos on Archaeopteryx we
learned that ken ham's exhibits often
contradict the findings of science today
right here we've learned that Ken hams
exhibits also contradict Ken hams other
exhibits brilliant now this looks bad
enough for Ken hams Mars exhibit but
things actually do get worse one of the
main plaques and the Mars exhibit states
the following the rejection of the
Biblical Flood is often due to
evolutionary biases rather than the
actual evidence in fact it is not a
stretch to think that nearly every
geologist would appeal to a global flood
to explain many of Earth's features if
the Bible had never mentioned such an
event
so here Ken Ham is claiming that the
reason geologists believe there is no
evidence for a global flood on earth is
because they want to believe in
evolution instead and because they don't
like the Bible that is Ken hams claim in
the next video of this series we're
going to take a quick look through
history to find out who was it that
actually first discovered that geology
does not support the idea of a global
flood who was it that made that
realization did it happen before the
theory of evolution existed or after the
theory of evolution existed was the idea
proposed by a theist that hated the
Bible or was it proposed by faithful
Christians who loved the Bible and live
their lives according to its teachings
I'm sure by now you can probably guess
the answer to those questions but it is
going to be an exciting video next
episode the history of geology is
absolutely fascinating so long for now
and let me just remind you as I bid
farewell to please be kind to people in
the comments
what I'm doing in this video series is
I'm revealing some major flaws with ken
ham's teachings and there are a lot of
people that really love Ken Ham and
they've been following him for a long
time some of them have been giving him
money
and when those people see how dishonest
the man is in the displays that he's
produced when they begin to realize how
inaccurate the things he teaches are
like that's just it's a painful
realization and a lot of people there's
this kind that there's this grieving
process that we go through and you're
going to see people in the comments
section that are in denial about the the
reality of this you're going to find
people in the comments section that are
really angry just let them blow off that
some steam
let them say what they want to say it's
okay we can be grown-ups about all this
so long
[Music]